how's the gum breath - Panama it's time
for another oculus rift horror game this
one is actually completely made for the
oculus so it should be interesting to
say the least
let's go oh this is even more real
because it's op ah what is good water
you don't wait oh okay here's my knit
hat what is down there oh [ __ ] that
oh [ __ ] me oh haha
alright I'm supposed to go to the X
[ __ ] great okay okay that's fine
we're live so so far so good oh whoa
what the [ __ ] oh I hope there's no sea
animals sea monsters seamen um coming up
oh this game is all that scary I feel
like I'm gonna eat oh [ __ ]
there's a creepy house over here
okay why don't we get Oh what that oh oh
this is freaking me a hag Oh what should
the wind no no no no no no tree hug me
hug me train Oh what the [ __ ] is going
on with this sound what in the heavens I
didn't mean to do it
I'm innocent oh [ __ ] that oh [ __ ] that
I am No Oh what the [ __ ] shut up shut up
trees you don't know me what what what
oh my head [ __ ] me not to go not the
girl we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine we're fine we're fine
you're right we're fine what am I
supposed to go buy a [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] okay we're fine we're
both chill this Jill this Jeff huh okay
okay
remember what your mom told you the men
working all day died like a little [ __ ]
no don't do that don't do that oh this
is so [ __ ] up ah seriously
what say anything what am I supposed to
do I don't want to die in a deal [ __ ]
huh-uh
I think our fine
that's not even [ __ ] stop what a hell
did I do to deserve this
oh come on come on come on come on what
am I supposed to throw in this [ __ ]
house no no no comprendo I do [ __ ]
[ __ ] walsim stop [ __ ] with me you
need it you mean you need a Shell pill
why the [ __ ] are we
I can't move can I are you [ __ ]
serious are you are you [ __ ] kidding
me
well I hope you're [ __ ] happy that
like when she's in your face you go back
if you're like uh and it doesn't work
it's so [ __ ] it's [ __ ] thought it's
sadist whoever makes a horror game for
the oculus is a scientist
they were like a junior watching buzz
hit subscribe to come over today all
I'll see you in the next one I'm gonna
take a bathroom break
they often both love you